اذا توجد تشارلز الثالث رسميا ملكا على
عرش المملكه المتحده في حفل رسمي هو
الاضخم الذي تشهده بريطانيا منذ سبعه عقود
بدات مراسم التتويج بموكب انطلق من قصر
الى كنيسه في لندن ومر الموكب باتجاه
ميدان الطرف الاغر الى ان وصل الى الباب
الغربي لكنيسه ويستمونستر بينما تجمهر
عامه الشعب في مناطق مشاهده الموكب منذ
السادسه صباحا بعد ذلك دخل الملك تشارلز
الكنيسه من الباب الغربي العظيم ثم سار
عبر صحن الكنيسه الى قاعتها الوسطى ليؤدي
الملك القسمه ويؤكد التزامه بالقانون
وتعاليم الكنيسه ثم بدات مرحله المسح
بالزيت المقدس للتاكيد على المكانه
الروحيه للملك الذي يعد ايضا راس الكنيسه
الانجليزيه
بدات مرحله تنصيب او لحظه التتويج حيث وضع
كبير الاساقفه تاج فوق راس الملك تزامنا
مع عز في الابواق واطلاق الاعينه الناريه
الاحتفاليه عبر انحاء المملكه المتحده
لذلك مرحله الجلوس على العرش ليغادر بعدها
موكب الملك الكنيسه بعد ان وضع على راسه
تاج الامبراطوريه ويعود من الطريق نفسه
الى قصر باكينجهم
وعقب تتويجه ملكا في كنيسه وسبنسر عاد
الملك تشارلز والملكه كاميلا الى قصر
باكينغهام حيث خرج الى شرفه القصر ووجه
التحايا للجموع المحتشده في محيط القصف
للملك وزوجته في شرفه القصر افراد الملكه
العائله
العائله المالكه في تقليد يعد لحظه مفصليه
في المناسبات الملكيه البريطانيه الكبيره
وتزامن ذلك مع تحليق تشكيلات الجويه فوق
القصر الملكي لدقائق عده
[موسيقى]